now to coronavirus outbreak which the
World Health Organization has now
declared a global health emergency a
hospital has confirmed the first case of
person-to-person transmission in the
u.s. the illness is blamed for more than
200 deaths in China and the State
Department now recommends no travel to
that country nearly 10,000 cases are
reported worldwide including six in the
US our lead national correspondent David
Begg know is in Loma Linda California at
a hospital where doctors are ready to
treat people evacuated from China this
week David what are you learning well
this is Loma Linda University Medical
Center and this is the emergency room
entrance but look what's right across
from it this tent that has been set up
they are using it they've used it in the
past for flu patients but now they're
using it to determine if someone might
have the corona virus once you come
inside you have the bed here you've got
some cots just a triage area and of
course the first thing they do is they
check your temperature
standard protocol if you're determining
whether or not someone has corona virus
listen this is the area where within the
last 48 hours you had more than 100
Americans come via plane from Wuhan
China they arrived here in hospital
officials said because they are here
let's mobilize our tent and prepare it
just in case anything that's in here
that you breathe out will go out and
then fresh air comes in so that things
aren't being exposed to the outside
if we didn't have the plane that came in
the reality is actually incredibly low
that we'd actually have to use it this
hospital is 11 miles away from March Air
Reserve Base that's where 195 Americans
were flown back from Wuhan China they
arrived here about 48 hours ago they
were asked to stay on the base for 72
hours they're being monitored for
symptoms Ian Thompson is one of them and
then if you turn around this way I
interviewed Thompson via Skype from
outside the airbase we couldn't get in
and he is abiding by requests from the
local health department not to leave
someone did try to leave yesterday but
was then told they could not leave and a
quarantine order was
Thompson who lives in Michigan says he's
anxious to get home you've been willing
to keep in touch with us and update us
other people aren't ready to talk do you
know why they may be scared that the
local areas probably get some negative
feedback when they get back the first
human-to-human transmission of the
corona virus in the United States has
been confirmed in Illinois it involves a
husband and wife the 60 year old woman
traveled to Wuhan last month her husband
did not public health officials are
investigating locations where the second
patient has visited in the last two
weeks in any closed context who were
possibly exposed worldwide the number of
cases is growing the World Health
Organization's declaration of a global
health emergency comes as more than 20
countries are fighting coronavirus
within their borders our greatest
concern is the potential for the virus
to spread to countries with weaker
health systems and which are ill
prepared to deal with it don't panic
that's essentially what the CDC said
yesterday I was on their call with a lot
of other media members they sounded
clear but they were calm and saying
listen there will be more cases of the
corona virus we expect it but we're
ready to deal with it jurika the number
one thing they said that everyone should
know is as of right now the federal
government does not believe that
Americans need to wear masks when they
go out in public that as of now all
right David bag no thank you so much